สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงแป๊บนึง
นะครับได้ค่ะสวัดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยพอ
ดีมันมี
ลมเดี๋ยวแป๊บนึงค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะคะ
งั้นเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่กันก่อนเนาะ
เดี๋ยวขอแชร์แป๊บนึงนะคะนัก
เรียน
อ่ะมาแล้วเนาะครูนิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะของ
ครูนิกวันนี้นะครับที่อเมริกาวันศุกร์
ครับวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 4 ครับเดือน
อะไร
คะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนครับปีพ.ศอะไร
คะ
ปีพ.ศ
256  6  5 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูนิกเวลากี่
โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะครับที่ครูนิกอยู่เนี่ย
เวลา
23 นอื 20:00 นเนาะตอนกลางคืนนะคะตอน
กลางคืนก็วันนี้วันศุกร์อ่าครูนิกเนี่ยทำ
งานมยคะวันศุกร์ปกติทำงานครับใช่คือของ
ครูนิกเนี่ยจะทำ
งานจะใช้คำว่าทำงานเป็นกะก็ได้ใช่อ๋อก็
คือทำงานไม่ได้เป็นแบบเค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
ไม่ได้เป็นเวลาว่าอ๋อครูนิกทำงานวัน
จันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์อ่า 99:00
นถึง 1800 น
ใช่อันเนี้ยคือทำงานเป็นเวลาประจำแต่ของ
ครูนิกเนี่ยทำงานเป็นกะทำงานเป็นกะมันก็
แต่ละ 1 แต่ละ 1 อาทิตย์เนี่ยมันก็จะไม่
เหมือนกันค่ะอ๋อก็คือเปลี่ยนเ้าแล้วใน 7
วันน่ะค่ะวันจันทร์เนี่ยถึงวันอาทิตย์ครู
นิกมีวันหยุดมั้ยคะมีครับมีมีสิต้องมี
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นะ
ไม่มีไม่ได้เว่าคุณอ้าเผื่อคุณนิแบบโอ้
ชอบทำงานมากเลยเจ้านายผมขอทำทุกวันได้
มั้ยครับเคยนะคุณนิก็เคยทำงานแบบทุกวัน
ติดกันเลยเนี่ย 1
เดือนใช่ตั้งแต่อ่ะตั้งแต่วันที่ 1 ถึง
วันที่ 31 อย่างเงี้ยล่ะคะสมมุติเนาะ
ประมาณ 1 เดือน
คุณนิกำลังจะคิด
ว่าชเอ่อเอ่อเคยทำแบบนานที่สุดเจริงๆแล้ว
เนี่ยเพิ่งนึกได้ว่าน่าจะ 4
เดือน
ใช่แต่ว่าอันนี้เนี่ยคือตอนที่ครูนิกไป
ที่ไปอยู่ที่ออสเตรเลียใหม่ๆอแล้วก็คุณ
นิกก็ไปทำงานที่ร้านอาหารคือร้านอาหารเขา
ก็จะแบ่งเป็น 1 วันเนี่ยจะมี 2 จะมี 2 กะ
กะเช้ากับกะเย็นแล้วก็ว่า 1 วันจะมี 2 กะ
1 อาทิตย์มี 14 กะคครูนิกะทำ 13
ก่ะก็คือมันจะมีครึ่งนึงอ่ะนี้ 12 ชมง
สมมุตินะอันนี้คูหญิงเดาประมาณให้เนาะ
แล้วก็มีกลางคืนเนี่ยอีก 12
ชมงครูนิกก็จะมีวันที่ครูนิกก็คือทำงาน 24
ชมเหรอคะจริงๆแล้วถ้าถ้ากลางวันกลางเอา
อย่างนี้ดีกว่าครับเพราะว่าเขาจะมีเพราะ
ร้านอาหารมันก็จะเป็นเหมือนมื้อเที่ยน
มื้อเที่ยงเนี่ยร้าก็จะเป็น 5 ชมงแล้วก็
มื้อเย็นก็ 5 ชมงก็เท่ากับว่ากะ 1 กะละ 5
ชมงอ่าไม่ใช่ 12 ใช่มย 55  12 ไม่มีเวลา
นอนนะเออใช่ค่ะก็กำลังงงนะคะอ๋องั้นคุณ
นี้ก็มีเวลาแหละแต่ก็ทำงานเยอะนะนะใช่
เยอะงั้นงั้นพอไม่ทำงานครูนิกมีเวลาครู
นิกก็ไม่ทำอะไรสิคะนอนอย่าง
เดียวนอนแล้วก็ซักผ้า
โเ้างั้นครูนิกไม่มีแบบเราเรียกอะไรงาน
อดิเรกหรอที่แบบว่าเพราะว่าวันเนี้ยครู
หญิงจะมาถามครูนิกเกี่ยวกับงานอดิเรกไง
ว่าเวลาที่ครูนิกไม่ต้องทำงานมีเวลาว่าง
สบายๆเนี่ยครูนิกชอบทำงานอดิเรกอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยจริงๆเนี่ยจริงๆมีมีมีครับงานอดิเรก
ของครูนิกเนี่ย
คือทำกับข้าวทำของกิน
อใช่เอใช่ได้ๆๆนะบางคนแบบงานอเดกของครู
คือถ้าครูนิกว่างจากการทำงานไม่ต้องทำงาน
ครูนิกก็จะชอบทำกับข้าวใช่มยคะใช่ทำไมคะ
ทำไมถึงชอบครูนิกเนี่ยชอบชอบกิน
แล้วเวลาอยู่บ้านเนี่ยเป็นวันว่างๆคุณนิ
ก็บเอออยากกินอันเนี้ยแต่ขี้เกียจต้อง
นั่งรถไป 1 ชมงไปกินแล้วก็ได้นิดเดียวอื
ทำเองดีกว่าทำเองดีกว่าใช่ออก็ตอนที่อยู่
ที่ไทยเนี่ยจะทำอาหารไม่ได้เยอะมากเพราะ
ว่าเราอยู่คน
เดียวแล้วไปซื้อของมาทำกับข้าวเนี่ยมัน
แพงกว่าอืเ้าถ้าอย่างงั้นทำถ้าคุณหญิงถาม
ครูนิกว่าครูนิกเริ่มทำกับข้าวเป็นงาน
อดิเรกเมื่อไหร่ก็คือตั้งแต่แต่อยู่
อเมริกาเหรอคะจริงๆเนี่ยก็ตั้งแต่อยู่ที่
ออสเตรเลียอืก็ตั้งแต่
โห 20 ตอนนั้นตอนนั้นอายุประมาณ 22  23
ก็ก็เกิน 10 ปีละ
อืก็คือเริ่มทำกับข้าวเป็นงานอดิเรกอัน
นี้คือผู้หญิงเคยเลยนะคะไม่เคยทำกับข้าว
คุณนิกกทำแบบอย่างอย่างแรกที่เคยทำเนี่ย
คือทำหมูกรอบ
อืใชโอโหเดี๋ยวๆๆๆนี่คะคุณทำคือทำไมคุ
หญิงโอ้โหเพราะว่าอย่างอ่ะอย่างคนอย่าง
ครูหญิงไม่ทำกับข้าวเนี่ยโอ้โหแน่นอนแต่
สำหรับคนที่ทำอาหารเนี่ยนะคะคือครูหญิงก็
เคยได้ยินมาว่าการทำหมูกรอบเนี่ยก็ไม่
ง่ายนะใช่มยไม่ง่ายใช่ไม่ง่ายเพรานัก
เรียนนี่คือหมูกรอบใช่เนี่ยครุณนิกำลังจะ
หาดูว่าที่คุณนิกทำอ่ะมันเป็นยังไงมีม
อ้าคือการทำหมูกรอบนี่คือยากมากๆนะคะยาก
แบบอูคือมันใช้เวลามันใช้เวลานานก็ครูนิก
เนี่ยทำหมูกรอบแล้ว
ก็คือคุณนิกชอบกินของทอดชอบกินอะไรกรอบๆ
ด้วยก็เลยเออหมูกรอบก็โอเคลองทำดูหา
Google แล้วก็ดูในวิดีโอว่าวิธีทำหมู
กรอบทำยังไง
อืก็เคยก็เลยเริ่มจากการทำหมูกรอบก็คือ
เริ่มจากอาหารที่เราชอบกินใช่ๆตอนนี้
กำลังสิ่งที่เราหารูปภาพไม่
เจอคืองานอดิเรกของครูนิกนี่ยากอยู่นะคะ
แต่ว่า
อร่อยอร่อยอร่อยใช่ก็คือคุณอทำขายด้วยนะ
ตอนช่วงโควิดตอนก่อนมา
อเมริกาใช่หืดูสิใช่นะนักเรียนอย่างตอน
ที่คนไทยหลายๆคนน่ะค่ะช่วงโควิดอ่ะ
ล็อกดาวน์อะไรอย่างเงี้ยหลายๆคนเนี่ยไม่
รู้จะทำอะไรนะคะงานอดิเรก
มคิดว่าเป็นสิ่งแรกๆที่คนไทยเลือกทำก็คือ
ทำอาหารทำ
เบเกอรี่ใช่คนไทยจะทำเพื่อนิทำเยอะมาก
เพื่อนคูนิทำเยอะบราวนี่ก็เยอะมากใช่คือ
หลายๆคนน่ะเริ่มจากแบบทำไม่ได้ทำไม่เป็น
จนทำแล้วก็เก่งแล้วก็ขายได้เลยอ่ะบราวนี่
คือเยอะมากเยอะใช่ก็อืคิเนี่ยตอนแรกก็คิด
ว่าเอ๊ะหรือจะไปทำบราวนี่กับเค้าดีแต่คุณ
นก็เออก็จริงๆเรารู้ว่าเราทำหมูกรอบได้ก็
เลยทำหมูกรอบขาย
อืในี่จตอนนี้ารูปไม่
เจอแต่ว่าถ้าเป็นครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะไม่นะคะ
ไม่ทำอาหารไม่ทำ
ขนมไม่ทำเค้ก
ไม่แล้วงานอดิเรกของครูหญิงคืออะไรครับ
จริงๆงานอดิเรกของครูหญิงก็คือครูหญิง
เนี่ยชอบต่อเลโก้ค่ะครูนิกนี่เนาะอ๋ออัน
นี้มีแค่ตุ๊กตา 1 ตัวนะคะเพราะว่าเลโก้
เก็บหมดแล้วไงเก็บๆๆอืใช่ก็จะชอบแบบแล้ว
ก็หึออเปล่าครับเป่า
ครับนี้จะบอกว่าออเจอรูปหมูกรอบแล้วจริงๆ
เจอแล้วแต่ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวให้ดูทีไม่เป็น
ไรให้ให้ครูนิกครูนิกให้นักเรียนดูก่อน
เลยค่ะนักเรียนอาจจะอยากเห็นหมูกรอบของ
ครูนิกอันนี้คือหมูกรอบของครูนิกเฮ้ยครู
นิกน่ากินนะเออเนี่ยแหละผู้หญิงอ่ะเป็นคน
ชอบหมูกรอบที่เนื้อหมูเนี่ยมันยังมีความ
แบบแบบเนี้ยเออเนี่ยแหละมันมีน้ำๆอ่ะค่ะ
อย่างอย่ารูที่ครูหญิงให้ดูจากอินเตอร์เน
น่ะหมูกรอบมันจะแห้งๆอย่างงั้นนะครูหญิง
จะแบบไม่ไม่ได้ชอบขนาดนั้นคือถ้าเอาไปทอด
เนี่ยมันจะแห้งแต่อันเนี้ยคุณนิกทำเนี่ย
ก็คือเหมือนเอาไปเข้าในเตาอบอือืใช่เนี่ย
แหละค่ะ
โอ้โหก็ขายได้นะคะใช่นั่นแหละก็ส่วนใหญ่
แต่ถ้าเป็นครูหญิงเนี่ยบอกแล้วไม่ทำอาหาร
นะคะไม่ทำนะถึงแม้ว่าจะมีเวลา
ว่างก็ไม่นะคะแต่ว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยคือเริ่ม
ต่อเลโก้ก็น่าจะประมาณช่วงแบบโควิดนั่น
แหละค่ะเพราะ
ว่าอยู่บ้านเนี่ยมีเวลาว่างเยอะครับคือ
ไม่รู้จะทำอะไรดูหนังดูซีรีส์ก็แบบก็
เบื่อแล้วอ่ะเจ็บตานะคะก็เลยไปคือประเทศ
ไทยมันจะมีร้าน Toy อันะคะเป็นร้านของ
เด็กนั่นแหละค่ะที่ว่าอเมริกาก็น่าจะมี
เหมือนกันก็จะมีแบบตัวต่อเลโก้ขายเนี่ยก็
เลยเอ้อมันก็ดีนะทำแบบว่าพอเราต่อใช่ไหมม
คะคือมันก็จะเป็นตัวแบบนี้ใช่ไหมมนัก
เรียนแต่อันนี้มันเป็นฟิกเกอร์เค้าเรียก
อะไรนะฟิกเกอร์ของเลโก้เท่านั้นน่ะคะ
อย่างเงี้ย
อืใช่เราก็ต่อใช่มต่อเออแต่ถ้าเป็นเลโก้
เป็นชุดแบบนี้อ่ะเนาะคือครูหญิงน่ะชอบอ่า
แี่ poter นะคะเลโก้
นะเนี่ยอย่างเงี้ยโอยากได้มากนะคะนัก
เรียนจริงๆอ่ะคุณนิกก็อยากซื้อเหมือนกัน
เลโก้ที่มันเป็นแบบแบบเนี้ยที่เป็นใหญ่ๆ
ที่สำหรับอสำหรับ
เอ่อเด็กอายุ 16 ปีขึ้นไปมันจะมีแบบยากๆ
ครูนิก็อยากใช่อุ๊ยครูนิคะมันจะมี
เลโก้เลโก้ที่เป็นอันเนี้ยครูหญิงอยากได้
มากเลโก้เค้าเรียกอาร์คิเทคแล้วเหอใช่อัน
นี้แหละอันนี้ก็คือที่ครูนิชอบครูนิก็
อยากได้เหมือนกันแต่แพงมากแพงมากค่ะคือ
ที่ไทยแพงมากกว่าอเมริกาอีกู้หญิงเคยอยาก
ได้ของอย่างอันบหรืออะไรสักอย่างอ่ะคือ
ถ้าเป็นพวก Architecture รุ่นไทยเอ้ยที่
อเมริกาจะประมาณ
200 เหรียญไม่รู้ว่าที่ไทยเท่าไหร่ที่
ไทยครูหญิงเคย
ดูคิดว่าอาจจะประมาณแพงกว่าอเมริกาจะ 5
500 ถึง 1,000 นะแต่ก็แล้วแต่รุ่นนะคะ
เออคิดว่าอาร์คิเทคนี่เกือบหมื่นอยู่นะ
น่าจะแบบแล้วแต่แล้วแต่ด้วยแหละว่าเรา
เป็นอะไรอาจจะถ้าสมมุติอเมริกา 200 ไทยก็
อาจจะประมาณ 8,000  8,000 บาทใช่ค่ะแล้ว
มันจะมีอีกอันนึงเหมือนกันที่เลโก้เขาจะ
เป็นเหมือนกับเาเรียกว่าเป็น
ศิลปะ
อ้อเคยเห็นมยเดี๋ยวนะเดี๋วไม่เคยเดี๋ยวคุ
นิเปิดให้ดูได้ไม่ไม่คือที่ไทยครูหญิงเคย
เห็นตึกตึกอะไรนะคะที่ดูไบอ่ะเมื่อกี้ครู
หญิงให้ดูเป็น Empire ใช่มไม่ได้อยากได้
อยากได้ตึกดูไบตึสใชเบรคาหรือเปล่า้น่าจะ
เบิร์สคาลีฟาแต่ว่าไม่ได้แพงมากนะคะตอน
นั้นครูหญิงจำได้ว่าครูหญิงดูราคาอ้อก็
แพงแหละก็เลยไม่ซื้อมาด้วยนะคะส่วนหนใช่ๆ
แพงๆจำะเออแพงๆอันนี้อ่ะเดี๋ยวนี่คุณนิด
จะเอาให้ดูอันนี้ไงที่คุณนิกบอกแล้วมัน
คุณนิคิดว่ามันสวยดีแล้วมันก็อันเนี้ย
ราคา 100  1 เหรียญอือือันนี้ถ้าผู้หญิง
คิดว่าถ้าที่ไทยอาจจะต้องไปดูที่ร้านของ
เลโก้เลโก Shop ที่ไทยมี 1 ร้านนะคะมี 1
ที่ที่สยามพารากอนแต่คิดว่าถ้าเอ่อทอยอัส
อะไรเนี่ยน่าจะไม่มีอใช่ค่ะครูหญิงรู้สึก
ว่าเวลาที่ด้วยความที่คุหญิงเป็นคนใจร้อน
ไงใจร้อนมากๆเวลาถ้าต่อเลโก้ตอนนั้นที่ทำ
อ่ะนะคะก็รู้สึกว่าเออมันทำให้เราเนี่ยใจ
เย็นแล้วแบบเราต้องดูเหมือนแบบจากเราที่
เป็นคนคิดคิดแบบ
อืมอย่างเงี้ยเข้าใจมคือเป็นคนที่แบบว่า
ไม่มีสเต็ปอ่ะเป็นคนคิดคิดอันนี้คิดอัน
นี้ฟังได้จากการพูดก็ได้นะคะบางครั้งพูด
พูดแล้วก็ยังพูดไม่จบอืเปลี่ยนเรื่องอีก
แล้วแล้วก็กลับมาใช่คุณ
ก็เลยรู้สึกว่าตอนนั้นเคยต่อ
เลโก้จำไม่ได้ว่าคิดว่าเป็น chines  New
Year ค่ะเป็นตรุษจีนใหญ่มากสวยมากเลยนะ
คะสวยมากเป็นเลโก้ที่สวยมากแล้วก็รู้สึก
ว่าเออเวลาเราเปิดดูแล้วก็ขั้นตอนที่ 1
อ่ะเอาขาใส่นะขั้นตอนที่ 2 เอาหัวใส่
อย่างเงี้ยมันรู้สึกว่าเออมันทำให้เรา
เป็นคนที่แบบใจเย็นลง
ก็เลยเออชอบนะคะเอใช่แล้วก็มีอีกอย่างนึง
ที่อันนี้เป็นเมื่อก้อนเมื่อก่อนนะคะครู
นี้ครูหญิงเคยทำเมื่อก่อนเลยนะคือครูหญิง
เคยเคยมีงานอดิเรกก็คือถักนิ้เอ๊ะเค้า
เรียกนิ้งมั้ยใช่มั้ยล่ะถ้าถ้าที่เป็นไม้
ยาวๆอ่ะใช่ก็จะเป็นนิติคือคุณนิกอ่ะจริงๆ
เมื่อก่อนตอนเด็กๆครูนิกจะชอบถักคนไทยจะ
เรียกว่าถักคอรสติอ่ะ
อ้าคือแต่อันนั้นครูนิกทำเพราะว่าพี่สาว
ครูนิกเขาชอบอครูนิกก็เลยออโอเคลองทำดู
แล้วพี่สาวคครูนิกซื้อแบบอันใหญ่ๆมาเลยก็
เลยพอพี่สาวคครูนิกรู้ว่าออนี่ไงนิกอ่ะก็
ทำได้ก็เลยให้ครูนิกทำูครูนิกอันนี้คือ
ผู้หญิงยังไม่เคยทำเลยนะคะหรอครับอันนี้
เดี๋ยวใช่มันเป็นอะไรที่แบบว่าใจเย็นมาก
เลยอ่ะครูนิกแต่จริงๆคสติอ่ะมันมันง่ายนะ
สำหรับครูนิกเดี๋ยวครูนิกจะอ่ะครูนิกเปิด
ให้ดูก็ได้อ๋อ
โอเคได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวหญิงเปิดให้ดูค่ะเดี๋ยว
ครูหญิงเปิดให้ดูนี่ๆเนาะอันนี้ก็ได้นะ
แต่ครูหญิงเคยเห็นเพื่อนทำนะคะปักออสิ
เนี่ย
อันนี้ใช่มั้ยแหละครับมันจะมันจะมีเข็มนะ
คะจะมีเข็มแล้วก็จะมีได้ด้ายคือมันจะปัก
เป็นแบบสี่เหลี่ยมเนาะแล้วก็ปักปักอย่าง
เงี้ยปักไขว้กันใช่มยใช่สมัยก่อนน่ะมันก็
คือมันต้องไขว้กันแบบนี้อืเนี่ยไขว้กัน
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะเห็นมั้ยอันเนี่ยเจะไขว้กัน
อืใช่
อ่า
หรือเ้าอันนี้อันนี้ของครูหญิงนะคะที่ครู
หญิงเคยทำก็คือถักนิ้นะคะถักนิ้แต่ว่านี่
ไงบางครั้งอ่ะปักปักออกมาเสร็จแล้วมันสวย
มากเลยนะเนี่ยรูปอย่างเงี้ยก็
มีใช่อันนี้ก็จะเป็นงอื
อืครูนิเคยทำว้าวแปลว่าคุณนิกต้องเป็นคน
ใจเย็นแน่ๆเลยอ่ะคือก็ไม่นะเพราะว่าที่ทำ
คติอ่ะคือทำเพราะพี่สาว
ทำก็ครุนิดก็จะก็ชอบทำเพราะว่าพี่สาวบอก
ว่าอยากให้เสร็จไวๆแล้วก็เหมือนบอกให้คุณ
ต้องมาช่วยทุกทุกอาทิตย์คุณนึกก็ได้ก็ไม่
ซีเรียสเพราะว่าก็ดีเหมือนกันเพราะถ้า
อยู่กับพี่สาวตอนเด็กๆแม่ก็จะไม่ว่า
ออเออแล้วพี่สาวก็ทำถ้าปักคนเดียวก็ใช้
เวลานานก็มีครูนิกช่วยอืใช่ก็แตู่หญิงไม่
เคยปักไม่เคยปักครอสตินะคะเคยแค่แบบถัก
นิ้ถักอยู่ประมาณ 1 ปีครับแล้วแบบผัก
เสื้อเนี่ยเสื้อสเวตเตอร์มันยากนะคะก็เลย
เลิกทำยากผู้หญิงได้ผ้าพันคอผ้าพันธุ์คอ
ง่ายก็โอเคนะเพราะคุณนิกอ่ะชอบคุณนิก
เนี่ยชอบผ้าพันคอแต่คุณนิกอ่ะถักนิ้งไม่
เป็นแม่คครูนิกเนี่ยเเคยทำให้อือืคือถ้า
พันคอเนี่ยมันจะมีแบบง่ายๆูหญิงเคยถัก
แล้วก็ให้คุณพ่อให้คุณแม่ให้เพื่อนนะ
เพราะว่าถักไม่ยากใช่มั้ยคะแต่ถ้าเป็น
หมวกเสื้ออ่ะพอแล้ว
โอเปลี่ยนดีกว่าเปลี่ยนนะโอเคใช่ค่ะเนาะ
นี่แหละค่ะแล้วก็แต่ว่าวิดีโอตัวันนี้มัน
ก็หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะครูนิกครับใช่หมดเวลา
แล้วก็จริงๆอยากรู้ว่านักเรียนเ่ะมีงาน
อดิเรกคืออะไรอะไรใช่อก็คอมเมนต์บอกเรา
ได้นะคะคอมเมนต์บอกได้แล้วเดี๋ยวเราจะไป
ดูแต่วันนี้ต้องไปแล้วได้ได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวเจอ
กันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะบ๊ายบายครับสครับ
สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะ